sentimientos encontrados y opiniones muy
diversas es lo que manifiestan los
ciudadanos tanto en rusia como en
ucrania ahora que la tensión entre ambas
naciones ha llegado a un punto álgido
entre infructuosas conversaciones
diplomáticas amenaza de sanciones y
mientras la comunidad internacional se
mantiene en vilo los civiles se
pronuncian desde moscú algunos respaldan
la decisión de putin otros consideran
que empeora las cosas
lucia no tenía opción tenemos que ayudar
a los separatistas no podemos dejarlos
solos en esta situación en medio del
fuego alguien tenía que hacerlo y ellos
no podían contar con ucrania
la situación geopolítica ya extensa con
europa y eeuu ahora será peor porque
están violando los acuerdos de mínimos
mientras tanto los residentes en quien
asumen el conflicto y no ocultan el
miedo
tengo mucho miedo yo no soy de kiev soy
de chernin y vo blast que está muy cerca
de la frontera con belarús y es
realmente aterrador el número de tropas
que está aumentando por allá físico
la visión es similar entre los que viven
cerca la región del tomba
me gustaría vivir nuevamente lo que pasó
en 2014 2015 y 2016 yo viví todo eso y
no fue nada agradable
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
reconoció el lunes la independencia de
las regiones separatistas de dónetsk y
lugar posteriormente pidió al senado
ruso poderes para intervenir estos
territorios según señaló para mantener
la paz esta solicitud ya fue aprobada
por unanimidad lo que ha disparado las
alertas en todo el mundo frente a lo que
sería a los ojos de occidente el
preludio de una invasión rusa a ucrania